mon patrimoine vivant retrouvez nous sur
notre site internet
bonjour à tous et merci de nous
retrouver sur public sénat à suivre dans
quelques instants en direct sur notre
chaîne la séance de questions cribles
thématiques aujourd'hui consacré à la
compétitivité c'est la fleur pellerin
la ministre en charge des thèmes de
l'innovation et de l'économie numérique
qui répondra aux questions des sénateurs
des questions qui portent
essentiellement aujourd'hui sur le
crédit impôt compétitivité et son
financement
et d'ailleurs il ya quelques temps le
gouvernement a précisé que pour financer
ce crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
l'une des mesures phares du pacte de
compétitivité issue du rapport gallois
les taux de la tva serait augmenté à
partir du 1er janvier 2014
alors si ça n'est pas le cas pour le
taux réduit qui est consacré aux
produits de première nécessité les
autres tours e augmenteront bien à
partir du 1er janvier 2014 le taux
intermédiaire passera de 7 à 10 % et le
taux normal de 19,6 à 20% alors tout de
suite
direction les mystiques pour cette
séance de questions cribles de
thématique consacré aujourd'hui à la
compétitivité
ban après midi à tous sur public sénat
point de pib par rapport à l'allemagne
à cela il convient naturellement
d'ajouter le poids du capital
la distribution des dividendes est
progressivement passé de 19 à 28 % du
profit des sociétés non financières
il existe donc une préférence pour les
actionnaires qui conduit à s'interroger
sur les faits réels qu'aurait une baisse
du coût du travail sur l'effort
d'innovation
madame la ministre ma question est
simple le gouvernement tente il prend
des mesures courageuses et notamment
allégé les charges financières des
entreprises car elles sont deux fois
plus lourde que les cotisations sociales
qu'elles versent dans leur ensemble
c'est-à-dire qu'elle pèse deux fois plus
sur la compétitivité des entreprises que
le coût du travail
merci je passe donc la parole à madame
fleur pellerin ministre chargé des
petites et moyennes entreprises de
l'innovation et de le
économie numérique merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur vous
rappeler à juste titre que la
compétitivité n'est pas uniquement une
question de coût qu'elle est un ensemble
de paramètres et c'est d'ailleurs la
raison pour laquelle nous avons le
gouvernement a souhaité présenter un
pacte pour la compétitivité la
croissance et l'emploi qui à côté de
mesures relatives au coût du travail
comportait 34 autres mesures à côté du
crédit impôt compétitivité emploi qui
concernait la compétitivité hors prix
donc c'est bien une démonstration de la
volonté du gouvernement de s'attaquer à
tous les déterminants de la
compétitivité et non pas seulement à
celui du coût du travail
alors vous reparler de l'accord national
interprofessionnel
conformément aux engagements de la
feuille de route social du mois de
juillet le gouvernement a en effet
négocié avec les partenaires sociaux un
accord qui je le crois
présente à caractère historique c'est un
accord qui est parmi qui est sans doute
le plus important sur le marché du
travail depuis plus de 30 ans nous avons
une situation macroéconomique qui est
très compliqué et nous devions y
répondre par des mesures concernant à la
fois des mesures pour relancer la
croissance
pour faciliter la réactivité des
entreprises mais également sécurisé et
accroître la protection dans l'emploi de
nos concitoyens et je crois que c'est
cet accord parvient à obtenir ce
résultat c'est tout d'abord un accord en
faveur de l'emploi puisqu'il mobilise
des levier structurels profonds en
facilitant le maintien dans l'emploi qui
est en cette période de chômage vous le
savez quelque chose d'extrêmement
important avec des fusils des outils qui
permettent à de favoriser la mobilité
interne et externe des salariés mais
aussi la simplification et l'unification
du dispositif de chômage partiel ainsi
que des accords majoritaires de maintien
de l'emploi les entreprises et les
représentants du personnel disposerons
davantage de levier pour préserver
l'emploi plutôt que de privilégier les
licenciements ce qui est je crois
important pour nos concitoyens
d'autre part c'est un accord qui apporte
des éléments de sécurité de sécurisation
juridique pour les entreprises c'est
aussi un aspect qu'il nous faut regarder
car les entreprises sont je crois qu'il
ne faut pas les opposer aux hauts
salariés celles qui créent de l'emploi
et qui crée également de la valeur mais
c'est aussi un accord qui permet de
faire reculer la précarité puisque il
n'est pas seulement quantitatif il porte
sur la qualité de l'emploi et sur le
recul de la précarité
et en améliorant les droits des salariés
quel que soit leur statut et la nature
de leur contrat de travail en incitant
les entreprises à recourir davantage aux
cdi plutôt qu aux cdd via la modulation
des cotisations et en améliorant la
situation des salariés à temps partiel
aujourd'hui les salariés les moins
protégés vous le savez sont en
particulier des tpe et des pme
et bien ce seront les premiers à
bénéficier des améliorations enfin c'est
un accord qui ouvre des droits nouveaux
individuels et collectifs pour les
salariés je crois que c'est très
important cet accord porte sur des
sujets extrêmement concret pour les
salariés puisqu'il améliore leurs droits
tout au long de l'heure de leur carrière
des droits individuels plus fort tout
d'abord avec un droit à la protection
sociale
une généralisation de l'accès et colas
ministères santé oui je finis des droits
les droits rechargeables mais aussi des
droits collectifs renforcée avec des
salariés qui seront davantage associer à
la stratégie des entreprises très bien
merci pour la réplique que monsieur
dominique watrin oui madame la ministre
je vous remercie de votre réponse
simplement vous avez souligné la
situation macro économique compliquée
que traverse de notre pays je n'en doute
évidemment pas cela dit faut aussi
préciser que la crise économique n'est
pas pour tout le monde devrait
simplement vous faire remarquer que les
dividendes versés aux actionnaires des
grands groupes du cac 40 sont restés
quasiment stables entre 35 et 40
milliards d'euros ces cinq dernières
années que les ajustements les
sacrifices ont toujours demandé aux
mêmes aux salariés voire aux retraités
vous avez répondu sur l'accord de
flexibilisation de l'emploi du 11
janvier
or elle a aussi attiré votre attention
sur un point fondamental
vous dites c'est un accord majoritaire
n'en c'est un accord minoritaire les
signataires cfdt cftc et cgc n'ont
récolté que 38% des voix dernières
élections prud'homales et 28% récentes
élections organisées dans les très
petites entreprises
et là encore eh bien nous avons des
choses à dire que nous dirons dans le
débat qui viendra mais il n'est pas
logique qu'on demande à travers des
reculs sociaux aux salariés de faire
toujours les
les sacrifices merci la parole est à
présent monsieur jean vincent placé pour
le groupe écologiste ce président madame
la ministre mes chers collègues
si nous organisons aujourd'hui un débat
autour de la compétitivité c'est
qu'évidemment elle suscite bien des
problèmes et des difficultés la
concurrence internationale d'un pin
sociale et environnementale et la hausse
du prix des matières premières sont des
réalités incontestable faut-il pour cela
comme notre collègue dominique watrin
lundi réduire les salaires renoncer aux
acquis sociaux des français et renier
parfois les enjeux environnementaux
non je refuse ce dogme et qui consiste à
s'aligner vers le bas au profit
l'économie déshumanisé déconnecté du
réel
je m'y oppose d'autant plus et c'est là
l'intérêt du débat que nous avons
aujourd'hui que d'autres voies sont
possibles pour relancer l'activité
économique tout en respectant les
objectifs du développement soutenable
aussi si nous voulons réellement sortir
des schémas du passé
innover et réinventer ce l'air cela est
possible
ainsi par exemple je vous propose
d'avoir une réflexion aujourd'hui sur
l'économie circulaire l'objectif de
l'économie circulaire et d'optimiser
comme vous le savez madame la ministre
les flux d'énergie et de matière pour
utiliser efficacement le minimum de
ressources et réduire la production de
déchets ainsi le conseil économique et
social et environnemental défini
l'économie circulaire comme un concept
qui englobe la réduction de déchets en
amont par l'éco conception des produits
le réemploi et enfin le recyclage mais
aussi l'économie de fonctionnalité qui
consiste au remplacement de la vente de
produits par la vente de services ou la
location
d'après l'onu 60% des services
actuellement rendu aux hommes par la
nature sont en déclin notre modèle
économique actuel linéaire et
productiviste est clairement
incompatible avec les caractéristiques
de planètes et urgence écologique aussi
les entreprises elles mêmes et
particulièrement les plus innovants de
notre pays aurait intérêt à développer
ses formes d'économie verte pour être à
nouveau compétitive et non pas courir
après des compétitivités du passé dont
on voit aujourd'hui les difficultés
réelles malgré certains discours de
matamore tenue en un mot elles
dégageront ainsi dégâts importants sur
le coût des matières premières et sur
l'approvisionnement des matériaux
renault ecopal michelin xerox d'autres
commencent à relever ce défi et par
ailleurs ces nouvelles formes d'économie
crée des emplois non délocalisables dans
le recyclage la maintenance la recherche
et de développement
la prévente ou encore le service des
achats l'allemagne la chine le japon
qu'on vote qu'on vante régulièrement
pour les aspects compétitivité l'ont
bien compris et se sont engagés le seul
président dans cette voie d'avenir un
institut d'économie circulaire a ainsi
été fondé récemment par le député
écologiste françois michel lambert aussi
ma question est extrêmement simple
est ce que le gouvernement souhaite
développer des conduites circulaire
économie trou ça a été dans notre pays l
quelles sont les prises de position qui
pourrait être celle de l'action
gouvernementale dans les mois à venir
je remercie la parole comme adam fleur
pellerin merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur alors oui le
gouvernement et en particulier le
ministère du redressement productif que
je représente aussi aujourd'hui devant
vous est très attaché à développer ce
concept dont vous appelez de vos voeux
le développement puisque vous avez bien
dit la raréfaction des matières
premières non renouvelables vous invite
à repenser également nos modèles
économiques qui soient des modèles
économiques plus rentable et plus
vertueux alors de quelle manière allons
nous procéder et bien déjà des premières
indications ont été données dans la
feuille de route sur la transition
écologique avec en particulier la
mobilisation de premier de plusieurs
leviers fiscaux qui pourront être
étudiées par exemple une augmentation
des taxes sur l'incinération et le
stockage pour favori pour valoriser et
favoriser la valorisation des déchets le
ministère du redressement productif bien
entendu soutiendra ces mesures est par
exemple pour illustrer ce propos il
suffit de savoir que la capacité de
traitement des déchets d'ameublement
deux sites de traitement existent
aujourd'hui en france est insuffisante
pour répondre à l'obligation
réglementaire qui fixe à 2015
l'obligation de recycler à hauteur de
45% les deux millions de tonnes mises
sur le marché chaque année
autre exemple les véhicules hors d'usagé
la france aussi est en deçà de ses
objectifs donc le ministère du
redressement productif va développer
veut développer nos capacités de valeur
isation de ses sous produits et pour
cela la ministre de l'innovation que je
suis vous le dis il est déterminant que
soit accordé des moyens importants à la
recherche développement le programme
d'investissements d'avenir prévoit
notamment pour 2013 250 millions d'euros
pour développer l'économie circulaire
alors deuxième point important la
sécurisation des débouchés est
évidemment fondamental pour assurer aux
acteurs une visibilité suffisante pour
leurs investissements et réduire leur
dépendance aux fluctuations des prix des
matières premières ce dispositif
envisagera évidemment en partenariat
avec les acteurs concernés au sein des
filières et entre filières les déchets
des en d1 pouvant devenir les matières
premières des autres ces principes
doivent être matérialisée dans le
contrat de filière qu'on demandait
conjointement arnaud montebourg est
d'être une bateau à l'issue du dernier
comme tu es filière stratégique des
éco-industries le 27 novembre dernier
donc nous voulons consolider les
filières existantes mais aussi innover
et déployer de nouveaux modèles
d'organisation
plusieurs actions du mrp sont lancés
pour favoriser l'économie circulaire je
vous en cite quelques unes le lancement
d'un pacte économie circulaire avec les
professionnels du recyclage qui suppose
des engagements réciproques gagnant
gagnant l'introduction dans la commande
publique de critères favorisant
l'utilisation de matières recyclées la
lutte contre les filières illégales
la structuration et le développement de
filières de démantèlement des matériels
de transport quels qu'ils soient
recyclés de l'industrie française et de
l'emploi et une réflexion pour réduire
le rythme de renouvellement des biens
d'équipement notamment les terminaux
mobiles
merci monsieur prise en place et je ne
voulais ce que 30 secondes vous avez
largement dépassé dans notre question et
vous avez raison c'est le président vous
savez être sévère et juste et je
soutiens votre action à cet égard m
ministre mes chers collègues merci de
cette réponse très complète qui m'a dit
que c'est bien bien volontiers à le
penser que le gouvernement est sensible
à cette question donc je ne peut que
l'inciter à poursuivre dans les voiles
vous avez indiquée à sensibiliser les
consommateurs à promouvoir davantage des
projets d'éco conception comme vous
l'avez indiqué vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs très honnêtement l'europe est
bien plus en avance que la france sur ce
sujet soutenir la recherche et
développement regroupe les acteurs par
exemple du recyclage pour en faire une
filière compétitive réaliser des études
prospectives pour identifier les
potentiels industriels solutions
novatrices
donc voilà les enjeux sont majeurs ils
sont là merci monsieur le président
merci mes chers collègues
et puis je suis très satisfait qu'on est
plus discuté de cela dans cet hémicycle
merci la parole est donc à présent
monsieur françois fortassin pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues lengronne
l'agroalimentaire est le premier secteur
industriel de notre pays dans un chiffre
d'affaires comme valeur ajoutée ils
représentaient 13 % de nos exportations
2012 c'est aussi le premier employeur
industriel français avec 4 5 à 15 me de
salariés dans ma région à l'image de
l'ensemble du territoire les entreprises
de l'agroalimentaire sont diversifiées
et innovantes
elle emploie dix sept mille personnes en
midi pyrénées et qui est caractérisée
par une forte prédominance des
industries de la viande les produits
laitiers
c'est la première région française sur
la fabrication de produits de salaison
de riz sèche et nous produisons 35 % de
la production nationale de jambon sec
avec la rolls des jambons secs qui est
le noir de bigorre
comme chacun le sait or le secteur agro
alimentaire risquent aujourd'hui de
traverser une crise grave
suite aux différents scandales que nous
connaissons mais surtout nos industries
alimentaires doivent faire face depuis
plusieurs années à des difficultés
structurelles à l'instabilité des cours
des matières premières
renforcé par la spéculation sur ces
derniers et une concurrence
internationale de plus en plus intenses
voire souvent déloyale
en effet comme dans bien d'autres
secteurs
nous assistons impuissants au pillage de
ne savoir faire les entreprises
chinoises ne bénéficient pas seulement
des transferts de technologies en
provenance du vieux continent mais elle
copie également des techniques de nos
producteurs de foie gras par exemple et
nous inondent leurs produits de qualité
plus que douteuse tout en fermant leurs
marchés aux nôtres est ce bien le
commerce international que nous voulons
l'agroalimentaire est un secteur
stratégique à défendre comme l'écrivait
nos collègues de la mission
d'information sur la
désindustrialisation des territoires
cette nécessité de défendre l'industrie
agroalimentaire est de plus en plus
prégnante dans un communiqué de presse
le 24 septembre 2012 et les ministres de
l'agriculture du redressement productif
et de l'agroalimentaire ont déclaré
je cite le rôle des pouvoirs publics est
d'aider les industries agroalimentaires
à mieux valoriser leur production et à
favoriser durablement leur compétitivité
internationale
ma question est donc simple madame la
ministre quelles mesures concrètes le
gouvernement d'entente il prendre
suivant quel calendrier pour renforcer
la confiance que la compétitivité des
entreprises agroalimentaires françaises
merci merci madame la ministre vous avez
deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur vous avez raison le rapport
gallois a mis en évidence un décrochage
de la compétitive en compétitivité
française depuis dix ans et notamment
dans le secteur de l'agroalimentaire
nous connaissons aussi un décrochage
réel à l'échelle intracommunautaires
alors il y à des questions de coût et en
effet les coûts de personnel
représentent 9% du chiffre d'affaires
produits par les entreprises d'abattage
découpage des ports par exemple mais 75%
de la valeur ajoutée de ces de cette
filière donc je crois qu'il ya
évidemment un aspect de compétitivité
coût auquel il faut bien entendu
s'attaquer mais également comme le dit
louis gallois dans son rapport il faut
rompre un cercle vicieux où la faible
spécialisation vous l'avez très bien dit
internationale en niveau de gamme
entraîne de faibles marges et de faibles
investissements qui à leur tour entraîne
une mauvaise ou une faible
spécialisation nous sommes donc
confrontés à la même problématique dans
l'industrie agroalimentaire que dans
tous les autres secteurs de l'économie
et la performance de nos industries dans
ce secteur implique des choix nouveaux
alors 60 pour cent de la main d'oeuvre
employée dans les abattoirs allemands
actuellement seraient étrangères et donc
ce n'est pas en luttant sur les coûts
que nous pourrons nous sortir par le
haut de cette situation
ce modèle je crois ne peut pas être
suivi en france et ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas souhaitable
donc au delà de cette discussion sur
l'application d'un certain nombre de
directives notamment la directive
détachement
nous avons besoin d'une stratégie
politique de production et c'est celle
ci que nous devons aujourd'hui partagé
je crois que cette stratégie doit
absolument s'appliquer s'appuyer pardon
sur des éléments de la compétitivité
hors coûts de nos industries
agroalimentaires le pont le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi sera évidemment
particulièrement utile aux entreprises
du secteur notamment dans les filières
viande
bien que son impact reste limitée par
rapport à l'ampleur du différentiel coût
du travail dans les abattoirs allemands
par exemple et donc sur les éléments de
compétitivité hors coûts la qualité et
l'image des produits vous avez fait
référence à une spécialité effectivement
tout à fait made in france qui qui
véhiculent ce savoir faire français
je pense qu'en terme de qualité et
d'image des produits nous aurons une
stratégie de montée en qualité de montée
en gamme qui sera absolument
indispensable pour promouvoir nos
produits à l'étranger
du côté de la production la diversité
des produits sous signe de qualité
permettra également de maintenir de
petites structures de production
transformation du côté du consommateur
évidemment une bonne lisibilité des
signes de qualité et de l'image france
pourra également favoriser
l'attractivité de nos produits je crois
qu'il serait important aussi travaillé
sur l'innovation puisque pour l'instant
les entreprises de l'industrie
agroalimentaire innove insuffisamment et
donc nous mobiliserons le crédit impôt
recherche indiquent les instituts
techniques agro alimentaires pour
accroître l'innovation dans la filière
très bien merci monsieur fortassin
madame la ministre je vous remercie pour
votre intervention
et je note avec plaisir qu'avec vos
collègues
nicole bricq arnaud montebourg sylvia
pinel vous avez effectivement
officiellement lancée le 30 janvier la
stratégie de marque pays sous le nom de
marque en france
toutefois je dois dire que je me
permettrai d'insister sur le problème la
traçabilité et en particulier sur la
viande qu'il y ait au moins les origines
des animaux abattus les date d'abattage
car au fond la traçabilité
c'est la vérité que nous devons aux
consommateurs
si mon cher collègue la parole est à
présent monsieur jean pierre raffarin
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire vous avez la parole monsieur
communiste merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre chers collègues je
revois à ras bord du gouvernement la
mini c'est de vous saluer je souhaite
aussi que vous puissiez transmettent la
gravité de notre sentiment à monsieur
montebourg et à toutes les autorités du
gouvernement qui ne sommes pas toujours
d'un sentiment d'avoir une conscience
suffisante de la grave crise de l'avis
de tempête industriel qui est
aujourd'hui annoncé sur notre pays pour
l'année 2013 déjà les chiffres de 2012
quand on voit l'explosion des faillites
+ 42 % de hausse des faillites sur la
fin de l'année aujourd'hui nous allons
vous en prie monsieur assouline on
ripaille ces choses là et je n'ai pas
d'esprit partisan dans tout cela
je sais qu'il ya des responsabilités
partagées sur l'histoire mais pensez à
tous ses salariés de l'automobile
aujourd'hui qui quand même nos groupes
allaient bien avait des difficultés et
aujourd'hui que nos groupes sont en
grande difficulté connaissent
différentes inquiétude et anxiété
aujourd'hui moi je pense aux 700
salariés d'autoliv à côté de poitiers
aujourd'hui qui sont menacés je pense à
tous ceux des fonderies renault que nous
avons réussi à à sauver l'année dernière
et qui aujourd'hui sont extrêmement
préoccupés par l'état de la situation ça
c'est pas de la gauche c'est pas de la
droite c'est de la bataille comme le
disait le premier ministre contre le
chômage
bataille première pour notre pays
respectez l'orientation qu'a été prises
par le pays tout ça pour vous dire que
dans cette situation aujourd'hui nous
sommes extrêmement préoccupés et je
voudrais vous dire que on comprend bien
que la ressource budgétaire aujourd'hui
est fait pour aider les entreprises
c'est pas pour une raison pour laquelle
il faut faire des ponctions mais il ya
des mesures qui ne coûtent rien et je
voudrais vraiment vous dire que il me
semble que le passage des seuils dans
notre pays est un sujet très grave
le nombre d'entreprises qui passent pas
de 9 à 10 qui ne passe pas de 49 à 5 ans
qui se passe pas de 149 1 150 il y a là
des blocages incroyable regardez le
nombre de pme aujourd'hui qui sont à 49
je crois qu'il faut aider au
franchissement des seuils
il faut réformer les seuls dans notre
pays il y alla de la flexibilité de la
compétitivité hors coûts il y a là des
possibilités de développement qui sont
donnés et ça on peut prendre
on ne peut pas prendre l'argument
financier pour refuser de telles
réformes je vous remercie
merci
madame fleurs peu de rêve merci monsieur
le président monsieur le premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je crois que le gouvernement
est en tout entier extrêmement conscient
de la gravité de la situation actuelle
si je crois tous et le gouvernement
sache et le est pleinement mobilisé pour
trouver des solutions à la fois pour nos
concitoyens qui souffre du chômage ou la
précarité mais aussi pour les
entreprises dont nous savons très bien
que la reprise la croissance et la
création d'emplois dépendent très
fortement alors je voudrais juste
insisté puisque vous parlez des seuils
de manière plus générale sur les mesures
que le gouvernement a prises pour venir
au soutien des pme
nous avons lancé il ya peu les assises
de l'entrepreneuriat dans le cadre
desquelles beaucoup de d'éléments
extrêmement importants soulevés par les
entrepreneurs sont examinés parmi
lesquels effectivement un certain nombre
de verrous qu'ils soient de nature
réglementaire fiscale ou autres qui
bloque le développement la croissance
l'exportation de nos entreprises où le
financement de nos prêts aux entreprises
en particulier les pme
alors sachez que dans le cadre de cette
réflexion il ya un groupe de travail qui
est consacré à la simplification la
simplification administrative notamment
qui vise à faciliter la vie quotidienne
des entreprises en limitant un certain
nombre de mesures en faisant en sorte
que les entreprises les pme notamment
soit conduite à à ne produire qu'une
seule fois un certain nombre de
documents qu'aujourd'hui on a tendance à
leur demander de produire 5 6 7 10 fois
dans l'année donc c'était une mesure que
nous appelons dites le nous une seule
fois qui concourra justement à permettre
aux entreprises de se concentrer sur
leurs activités et non pas sur des
démarches administratives qui prennent
du temps coûte de l'argent et ne
rapporte rien aux entreprises
et effectivement il ya aussi une
réflexion dans le cadre de ce groupe de
travail sur la simplification sur la
question des seuils qui est en train
d'être examinées parce que vous l'avez
raison c'est une problématique qui est
souvent soulevée mais que nous avons du
mal à étayer quantitativement c'est à
dire que l'impact macroéconomique de
cette problématique des seuils n'est
pour l'instant pas suffisamment
documenté donc nous regardons avec les
services sur lesquels je n'appuie pour
les entrepôts les assises de
l'entrepreneuriat qu'elles sont en effet
les les blocs la jsa et sachant que nous
avons un certain nombre de contre
exemple je pense à une entreprise comme
criteo qui est aussi une entreprise du
numérique qui l'entreprise qui a connu
une croissance à deux chiffres au cours
des cinq dernières années
et qui a réussi à franchir ces plafonds
de verre donc nous travaillons aussi
avec les entreprises qui ont réussi à
dépasser ces problématiques pour voir de
quelle manière nous pouvons aider les
autres à suivre le même parcours mais
sachez que nous avons bien ces questions
en tête
très bien merci monsieur raffarin merci
madame la ministre de cette question qui
en partie correspond de cette réponse
qu'en partie correspond à ma question
mais elle je voudrais simplement vous
dire que ma conviction c'est qu'il ya
vraiment urgence sur ces sujets depuis
un certain nombre d'années je suis élu
je peux vous dire très franchement
peut-être depuis plus d'une trentaine
d'années je n'ai pas vu de situation
économique aussi tourmentée que celle
nous vivons actuellement c'est
simplement pour vous aider à améliorer
l'urgence de la situation merci la
parole est à présent monsieur aymeri de
montesquiou pour le groupe union des
démocrates et indépendants eu ces
aidants monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues
mam le ministre vous avez hérité d'une
situation difficile la politique de
votre gouvernement l'a aggravé notre
préoccupation à tous c'est le chômage
que notre médiocre compétitivité aggrave
la compétitivité englobe la qualité de
la main d'oeuvre
le coût du travail et la qualité du
management
votre politique maintient que le travail
toujours excessif et entraîne l'exil des
cadres voudrait supprimer la tva sociale
qui baissaient les charges et donc le
coût du travail plus compétitif
nous aurions importé moins exporter plus
diminuant notre déficit commercial
notre chômage et accroissant les
capacités de financement de nos
entreprises basées sur l'augmentation de
la masse salariale
le crédit impôt compétitivité trop
complexe est il approprié aux pme ne
bénéficiera qu'aux entreprises en
croissance et pour les autres rien il
favorisera surtout les grands groupes
dont l'activité s'exerce autant à
l'étranger et non les pme fragilisées
par la crise et qui donc n'embauche
guerre
de plus les auto entreprises et les tpe
en sont exclus votre crédit d'impôt se
résume un crédit d'embûches pour les
grandes entreprises
chacun conviendra que pour être
compétitive de l'entreprise doivent
investir on leur capacité
d'investissement a été laminée par une
hyper taxation décourageante qui ôte
l'envi également moteur de compétitivité
nam le ministre quelles mesures fiscales
incitatives
comptez-vous mettre en oeuvre pour
améliorer la compétitivité de nos pme
afin qu'elles puissent affronter la
concurrence internationale
merci madame la ministre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur alors tout d'abord pour vous
répondre sur le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi
ce crédit d'impôt compétitivité emploi
il est destiné aux pme en premier lieu
nous allons commencer à aller dans les
régions et à informer les préfets de la
manière dont ce crédit s'appliquera et
notamment son pré financement qui est
très important pour soulager les
difficultés de trésorerie des pme
à partir de cette semaine et ce crédit
d'impôt sera extrêmement facile à
utiliser les pme connaissent très bien
le mécanisme du crédit impôt recherche
salah procédera exactement de la même de
la même méthode donc la plupart des
enfants tous les creux de l'époux pme
que nous avons rencontrés et à auquel
nous avons présenté ce dispositif voit
très bien comment elles vont l'utiliser
et le mobiliser je rappelle tout
simplement que ce cicr représentera
l'équivalent l'équivalent d'un
allègement de charges de 12 milliards
d'euros en 2013 et de 20 milliards en
donc lorsque vous dites que le
gouvernement ne fait rien en matière
d'allègement du coût du travail je pense
que vous ne pouvez pas tout à fait dire
cela
les pme
je le précise pourront solliciter le
préfinancement du cic eu directement
auprès d'oseo dès cette semaine
d'ailleurs puisque la banque publique
d'investissement a commencé à opérer en
cédant la créance du crédit impôt éviter
emplois qu'elles ont sur l'état et les
banques commerciales elles aussi
pourront proposer le préfinancement du
cicr à compter du début du 2ème du
deuxième trimestre alors de manière plus
générale que faisons nous pour améliorer
la compétitivité des pme ou des
entreprises de manière plus générale
dans la compétitivité dans la
compétition internationale
je crois que nous avons pris un certain
nombre de mesures qui visent en tout cas
pour les pme qui me tiennent à coeur
pour des raisons que vous pouvez
imaginer
nous avons pris des mesures importantes
pour soulager la trésorerie des pme
je vous rappelle que nous avons dans le
cadre du pacte de compétitivité
instaurer un dispositif pour venir en
aide aux pme en matière de trésorerie
doté de 300 millions d'euros donc ce
dispositif permettra vous savez il ya un
certain nombre de défaillances qui sont
liés à des difficultés de trésorerie à
court terme permettra de venir en aide à
ses entreprises les plus fragilisées
notamment pour des raisons de non
respect de délais de paiement par les
grandes entreprises et parfois même par
des collectivités publiques
nous avons mis en place également le
préfinancement du crédit impôt recherche
qui là aussi sera une 10 qui
n'existaient pas auparavant qui
permettra aux pme d'anticiper sur l'or
que leurs créances et ainsi de résoudre
également des problèmes de trésorerie
alors la bpi vous le savez est
opérationnel également depuis la semaine
dernière je crois que c'est aussi une
façon pour l'état de mieux orienter
l'épargné des français vers les pme
et vers les entreprises de croissance la
simplification de la vie des entreprises
à laquelle j'ai fait allusion tout à
l'heure est également un élément qui
permettra d'améliorer la compétitivité
des entreprises et enfin je les ai
rappelés les assises de
l'entrepreneuriat sont également un
événement tout à fait inédit dans la vie
d'attaqués dans le menu permet de
recentrer la discussion avec les
entreprises est de trouver des solutions
concertées avec merci monsieur de
montesquiou le ministre merci pour votre
réponse qui ne satisfait pas parce que
tout le monde ici a conscience de
l'inquiétude des salariés de
l'inquiétude des entrepreneurs et donc
le site qui a décidé tout à l'heure par
jean pierre raffarin plus 42% de
faillite
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment quelque chose
de dramatique
or votre projet crédit compétitivité
impôts compétitivité s'adresse aux
entreprises qui embauchent
aujourd'hui les pme non gauche peur vous
voyez même un phénomène tout à fait
nouveau c'est que les chefs
d'entreprises préfèrent retirer les
maigres profits qu'ils font plutôt que
de les réinvestir
il ya une perte de confiance il ya une
perte d'environ vous voulez bien un
symptôme extérieur extrêmement
inquiétant 27% étudiants qui ont fait
des études supérieures préfère envisager
une carrière à l'extérieur aujourd'hui
redonner l'envi par une fiscalité
incitative marolles et à monsieur jean
jacques mirassou pour le groupe
socialiste apparentés mercier monsieur
le président madame la ministre je vais
à ce qui me concerne à bord d un secteur
industriel qui n'est pas sinistré loin
s'en faut je veux parler de l'industrie
pharmaceutique de la recherche
afférentes puisque ce même secteur
d'activité nous participe à ce qui
concerne notre commerce extérieur et sa
place à amoindrir le coût de puisqu'il
est effectivement excédentaires mais
pour autant le conflit qui se déroule à
toulouse sur une question qui engage la
survie le mot n'est pas trop fort de son
centre de recherche avec 614 peuple à la
clé et quand même sérieusement
démonstratif de lendemains qui
pourraient déchanter je m'explique
la révoquer tout à l'heure la fille dans
une région de lacs de certaines
activités
là c'est le cas il est évident que dans
un moment où on sert davantage les
actionnaires ont réduit la r&d et bien
quelques nuages s'amoncellent à
l'horizon
ça veut dire que dans le même temps
aussi quand on favorise
l'externalisation de la r&d par le biais
des start up ou en engageant des
recherches à l'étranger
on met véritablement en danger le
potentiel de recherche de cette
industrie est en même temps en alimente
l'inquiétude dix chercheurs qui sortent
le fait de leur coeur de métier et qui
considèrent à juste titre que leur corps
de métier c'est d'inventer des
médicaments pour soigner les gens
donc ça veut dire pratiquement que le
sentiment qui est celui que je vais
développer là est un sentiment
d'inquiétude des salariés en question
que je partage et qui peut dans les 10
15 ans qui viennent remettre en cause à
la fois une stratégie industrielle
payante 5 a dû dire et en même temps une
stratégie sur le plan sanitaire et
j'aimerais savoir madame la ministre
quel est le sentiment du gouvernement à
ce sujet merci madame la ministre vous
avez la parole pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur si vous permettez j'aimerais
quand même revenir sur un chiffre le
nombre de défaillances d'entreprises a
été de 59 me en 2012 soit une
augmentation de 2 7% par rapport à 2011
est par ailleurs le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi s'applique à toutes
les entreprises puisqu'il est fonction
de la masse salariale en dessous d'un
certain salaire calculé en fonction du
smic et non pas aux seules entreprises
qui embauchent 7
cette précision est en fait sur les
industries de santé
la france croit fait partie des grandes
nations en matière d'industrie
pharmaceutique nous avons des champions
nationaux
nous avons une recherche développement
extrêmement fortes et puissantes et donc
tout cela justifie bien sûr le maintien
d'un secteur à haut niveau de
productivité en la matière les effectifs
salariés globaux de la pharmacie ses 500
3000 emplois directs depuis les années
2000 sans impact net pour l'instant de
la crise et si l'on considère l'ensemble
de la chaîne du médicament
ce sont 310 mille personnes qui
travaillent dans l'industrie du
médicament alors vous avez raison il
s'agit d'une industrie qui est néanmoins
en forte mutation et qui donc
doit être accompagnée et sera accompagné
par le programme d'investissements
d'avenir
je vous rappelle que le secteur de la
santé qui constitue une des priorités ce
programme d'investissements d'avenir et
bien mobilisera on estime plus de 10 %
des 35 milliards d'euros que représente
globalement les investissements du pays
à la spécificité de la filière vous
l'avez dit réside dans la diversité des
entreprises qui la composent à la à côté
des grandes entreprises des très grands
groupes il y a également un nombre
important de petites entreprises de pme
et d'entreprises de taille intermédiaire
qui ont un grand potentiel de recherche
et d'innovation qu'il faut absolument
mobilisés alors qu'allons nous faire la
prochaine d'une prochaine réunion du
conseil stratégique des industries de
santé
le css est prévue pour juin 2013 vous le
savez cette institution permet aux
gouvernements et aux industries de santé
de d'affirmer la vocation de la france à
demeurer un grand pays en matière de
sciences du vivant et de la santé
le strat et le comité stratégique des
filières un des industries et
technologies de santé a également pour
vocation de mieux structurer au plan
national la filière des industries de
santé en y intégrant ces différents
secteurs médicaments biotechnologiques
outils diagnostiques et c'est avec
l'aide des partenaires sociaux des pôles
de compétitivité et des organismes de
recherche
la feuille de route du conseil
stratégique et des reposeront définitif
sur deux grands axes confortait la
capacité de recherche et d'innovation de
la france et soutenir les industries de
santé en tant que filières stratégiques
pour la compétitivité la croissance et
l'emploi
si monsieur mirassou faisait des paroles
commentaire monsieur le président madame
annie strad expliquant que là comme
ailleurs où là plus qu'ailleurs le
gouvernement de voir et/ou droit
d'ingérence puisque faut-il le rappeler
les remboursements des médicaments sont
payés et financé par les contribuables
au même titre du reste que le crédit
impôt recherche est donc
l'objectif qui est le mien vous interpro
l'âme d'un ministre c'est aussi
d'insister sûr ce point de vue là qui va
permettre au gouvernement de s'activer
davantage dans le cadre du cas évoqué en
termes une organisation de filière est
la parole et à monsieur francis delattre
pour le groupe union pour un mouvement
populaire
le président madame le ministre dans les
lois de finances
cet été rectificatif le gouvernement
vous avez pré lever 13 milliards
d'impôts et taxes supplémentaires sur
les entreprises et dans le même temps
alors que les marges étaient au plus bas
que les investissements des entreprises
s'écrouler il était pour le moins
aberrant de supprimer dans l'urgence le
dispositif de la tva anti délocalisation
qui transférait 13 milliards d'euros de
charges sociales aux entreprises vers la
fiscalité ce qui aurait produit ses
effets des premières octobre 2012 pour
améliorer la situation financière de nos
entreprises
vous avez essayé de réparer cette bévue
en reprenant l'analyse partiellement du
rapport gallois sur la nécessité d'un
choc de compétitivité devenu en fait un
pacte avec le crédit d'impôt pour la
compétitivité l'emploi
malheureusement aujourd'hui cette
urgence n'a reçu aucun début
d'application et ceci m'amène ma liste à
vous poser trois questions
au delà du verbiage d'une instruction
fiscale pouvez vous nous préciser les
modalités de son emploi pour l'année
2013 ce dispositif de 20 milliards
d'euros étaient devait être financé à
parité par la fiscalité que nous
connaissons et par 10 milliards
d'économies que nous ne connaissons pas
à la milice aujourd'hui pour vous et
nous nous préciser nous indiquer les
contours de ces économies à défaut ce
pack se réduirait à l'habile plan de
communication quid ensuite des 19 autres
propositions du rapport gallois
notamment quid des propositions que le
rapport appelait le complément
indispensable au choc de compétitivité
et en particulier les mesures
pour renforcer les fonds propres des
entreprises pour soutenir leurs
investissements dans une période où tout
le monde sait qu le crédit bancaire se
fait rare avec les applications des
directives de bâle iii caen et
himalayiste de la réorientation vers les
pme et anti tpe à des plans d'épargné en
actions et plus généralement du
développement de l'actionnariat des pme
dans un cadre fiscal non pénalisants
visible par rapport à d'autres
placements en vous rappelant
qu'aujourd'hui les investisseurs qui
soutiennent l'économie réelle sont de 4
millions de personnes alors qu'ils
étaient il ya deux à trois ans 7
millions très bien la parole et à madame
la ministre monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi comme j'ai dit tout
à l'heure c'est effectivement un effort
de l'état pour les entreprises de 20
milliards d'euros j'insiste sur ce
chiffre puisque vous faisait référence
vous même à 13 milliards d'euros de la
tva qui reporte qui reposait sur le le
consommateur et donc les les
consommateurs français ne concitoyens
sans distinguer d'ailleurs parmi ceux
qui sont les plus riches et ceux qui
sont les plus défavorisés donc le crédit
impôt pour la compétitivité à l'emploi
vise à créer comme le demandait
d'ailleurs louis gallois dans son
rapport un choc de confiance et à
permettre à nos entreprises de renouer
avec l'employée avec l'investissement
donc je lui ai dit tout à l'heure c'est
sera tout d'abord un allègement de 12
milliards en 2013 le temps à monter en
charge plus de 20 milliards en 2014 de
charges patronales qui pèseront sur le
travail et qui seront ainsi alléger les
pme les 10 pourront solliciter le
préfinancement du crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi directement auprès
de la bpi bld oseo d'abord en cédant la
créance crédit impôt compétitivité
emploi qu'elles ont sur l'état les
banques commerciales pourront elles
aussi avec la garantie d'oseo assurer ce
préfinancement c'est un mécanisme
extrêmement simple il suffira aux
entreprises de calculer le montant de
crédit impôt auxquelles ils ont droit et
puis de présenter ce calcul à la banque
publique d'investissement ou à une
banque commerciale pour obtenir le prêt
financement du crédit un peu
compétitivité emploi
vous m'interrogez ensuite sur les
dispositions en faveur des fonds propres
des entreprises il ne nous a pas échappé
évidemment dans le diagnostic que nos
entreprises souffrent d'un taux non
seulement d'un taux d'autofinancement
qui est plus faible que celui des pme
je parle des pme en particulier mais ça
vaut pour toutes les entreprises que les
autres pme européennes mais également
qu'elles ont des difficultés dans
l'accès aux fonds propres que
l'industrie du capital-risque est
insuffisamment ou du capital
développement est insuffisamment
développée en france et là encore la
banque publique d'investissement qui
sera doté de 40 milliards de plus de 40
milliards de fonds propres sera une
réponse puisqu'elle permettra c'est la
banque des pme elle permettra de
répondre à la fois en crédits et en
apport de son propre aux difficultés de
financement des pme
donc vous avez là une réponse
extrêmement concrète à comparer à je ne
sais pas quel bilan du gouvernement
précédent
enfin s'agissant de l'épargné vers les
pme le président de la république s'est
engagé à construire un produit d'épargné
pea pme destiné à orienter l'épargné des
ménages épargnent est abondante en
france l'entreprise vers les pme
merci monsieur delattre nous apprend des
choses intéressantes c'est que c'est la
bpi qui va financer en partie des
dépenses qui sont quand même visiblement
de fonctionnement puisque ces
déremboursements avancer le problème
c'est près de la créance parce que la
créance avec les conditions les
conditions qui ont été imposées à
l'assemblée nationale font que la
créance n'est pas certaine donc ça
posera des problèmes juridiques
en fait le volet le plus important pour
moi c'est quand même les fonds propres
et 2
de dire que c'est uniquement à travers
la bpi moi je pense que c'est un travail
l'actionnariat l'héparine privé qu'il
faut essayer de réorienter les choses et
que je pense qu'en termes de force de
frappe
ces 2 2 que les contribuables que les
actionnaires aient un peu de lisibilité
c'est ce qu'ils demandent d'abord et de
nous expliquer que c'est uniquement par
fonds publics que nous allons redonner
l'ensemble de nos entreprises des moyens
suffisants je ne pense pas on aime le
ministre merci je fasse la parole à
présent à monsieur yannick vaugrenard
pour le groupe socialiste et apparentés
merci monsieur le président madame le
ministre mes chers collègues relancer la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
nécessitent des actions dans différents
domaines et beaucoup ont déjà été
évoqués je voudrais pour ma part vous
interroger sur la simplification
administrative
la complexité parfois administrative
pénalisant fortement nos entreprises et
ceci quel que soit leur taille par
ailleurs en effet elle seule l'action
des élus locaux est encadrée par la
somme phénoménale de 400 mille textes
réglementaires qui circulaire est bien
entendu ça ne date pas d'hier c'est
texte s'applique aussi par ricochet aux
entreprises travaillant avec les
collectivités locales
le classement 2012 2013 du world
economic forum place d'ailleurs la
france au 126e rang sur 144 pays en
matière de complexité administrative
à titre d'exemple on constate qu'il faut
six ans et demi en moyenne deux
procédures en france pour pouvoir
débuter la construction d'une ligne à
haute tension à haute tension bardon
lorsqu'il faut trois ans en autriche et
deux ans et demi au danemark
et cette lourdeur un coup tellement ils
devaient parfois qu'il peut aboutir
al'inverse de l'effet recherché à savoir
une règle excessive devenant vite dû
finalement inapplicable le gouvernement
précédent avait affirmé cette saisie du
problème
malheureusement les études annonces
n'ont été suivies d'aucune action
concrète comme c'est arrivé fréquemment
et la commission dite de la paperasse
comme il est d'usagé de la nommer est
restée lettre morte
le gouvernement actuel a d'ores et déjà
au pu montrer son efficacité puisqu'il a
confié d'une part alain lambert
par jean claude boulard maire du mans
une mission en vue d'alléger les normes
applicables aux collectivités locales
leur objectif étant de lister d'ici au
15 mars prochain
donc les délais sont rapprochés des
textes jugé absurde et pouvant être
facilement abroger le ministère de
redressement productif a de son côté
lancé avec pierre moscovici marylise
lebranchu et vous même madame la
ministre
une première réunion de concertation
avec les entreprises sur le programme de
simplification de leurs démarches
administratives et de leur environnement
réglementaire vous pouvez vous nous
présenter madame le ministre les
premiers éléments qui sont ressortis de
cette concertation ainsi que les
orientations du gouvernement sur ce
sujet d'importance je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre s'il vous plaît
merci monsieur le président
effectivement nous avons eu un premier
groupe de travail dans le cadre de ce
groupe interministériel de coordination
de simplification pour les entreprises
avec marylise lebranchu pierre moscovici
le 4 avril dernier
non par le 24 avril pardon le 4 février
dernier
alors les pros les projets sur lesquels
nous travaillons actuellement et qui
sont là vous allez le voir extrêmement
concret il ya d'abord le projet que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure lors d'une
précédente réponse c'est le projet dites
le nous une seule fois ce projet
consiste effectivement à réduire à
déceler d'abord les redondances puis à
les réduire et donc les principales
déclarations sociales seront examinées
pour que nous puissions supprimer celles
qui sont redondantes dès 2013 deux cent
cinquante mille entreprises
bénéficieront d'une déclaration pré
remplie de la c3s à la contribution
sociale de solidarité des sociétés
ce sera une aussi un gain de temps
considérable pour les entreprises et par
ailleurs le gouvernement est bien décidé
à accélérer le mouvement déjà engagé en
faveur de l'as des matériels
dématérialisation des attestations
fiscales et sociales qui sont à fournir
dans le cadre des procédures de marchés
publics
les déclarations sociales seront
unifiées dès le premier semestre 2013
des solutions seront proposées pour
simplifier et accélérer les procédures
applicables à l'immobilier des
entreprises nous allons également mettre
en oeuvre
un portail unique dead puisque nous
avons procédé également à ce travail de
recensement des aides publiques aux
entreprises qui se comptent en milliers
et donc nous allons créer un portail
recensant les aides publiques qui sera
ouvert et intégré au portail unique de
la création d'entreprise guichet tirait
entreprises.fr sera aussi rénové ce
portail ou couvrira pour ouvrira pour
mika demi 2014 l'ensemble des formalités
prise en charge par les centres de
formalités des entreprises depuis la
création jusqu'à l'association ou la
radiation
nous allons travailler aussi sur un
sujet que vous évoquez qui est très
important qui est la lutte contre la sur
transposition du droit communautaire
c'est à dire le fait pour le droit
français d'imposer des normes des
réglementations qui sont encore plus
contraignantes que les normes
communautaires
nous allons procéder aussi aux tests pme
qui était une promesse du président de
la république pour évaluer l'impact de
toute nouvelle réglementation sur les
pme le test pme ce sera aussi une façon
pour nous d'améliorer et de simplifier
les relations entre l'administration
leurs six ans et demi monsieur yannick
vaugrenard
oui merci beaucoup madame la ministre de
la précision de votre réponse qui
montrent qu'au delà des discours le
gouvernement est très sensible aux
préoccupations des entreprises notamment
dans le domaine des démarches
administratives
ça montre bien que
le gouvernement est à l'écouté qu'elle
n'a pas la responsabilité aujourd'hui de
la situation difficile dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons qu'il a bien
conscience
bien entendu comme tout le monde que le
pays traverse une phase économique et
sociale et financière particulièrement
difficile mais que c'est pas en moins de
10 mois qu'on peut régler les choses et
qu'il est qu un peu inconvenant je
trouve que ce que la responsabilité
pendant de dix années se permettent
aujourd'hui de donner le saut est de
dire que notre gouvernement ne serait
pas suffisamment conscients de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
surtout que ce sont les mêmes qui ont
caché les suppressions d'emplois juste
avant les élections présidentielles
merci la parole est à présent à madame
marie noëlle lienemann pour le groupe
socialiste et apparentés madame la
ministre
on parle souvent dans la compétitivité
des coûts du coût du travail mais je
suis frappé du fait qu'on ne parle pas
des coûts du de l'immobilier du logement
or des études ont été faites par l' ocde
qui montre que chaque fois que nous
avons une augmentation d'environ 10% des
prix de l'immobilier
nous voyons baisser nos exportations de
1 3%
par ailleurs des études comparatives sur
la compétitivité française la
compétitivité allemande ont mis en
exergue la flambée des prix et notamment
la forte augmentation des dépenses des
loyers des dépenses de logement dans la
consommation des français
du coup on peut observer qu'en dépit de
le salaire extrêmement qui n'ont pas
connu d'augmentation en allemagne voire
dans certains cas des reculs le pouvoir
d'achat des allemands a été très limitée
par le fait que les dépenses de logement
n'ont pas évolué alors que dans le même
moment en france elles augmentaient de
plus de 15 à 20% ainsi un chômeur peut
dépendre un chômeur à smicard peut
dépenser jusqu'à 40% de son salaire pour
se loger et vous voyez bien que quand on
augmente très faiblement salaires et que
les loyers augmentent ou le logement
augmentent de 10 à 12%
eh bien on a une perte nette de pouvoir
d'achat
en dernier lieu l'augmentation des prix
de l'immobilier est un mécanisme
spéculatif qui ne dissocie pas le
logement de l'immobilier d'entreprise ou
de commercial et que ses dépenses
d'immobilier d'entreprise d'immobilier
commercial pèse lourd pour certaines
entreprises
en conséquence je vous demande quelles
dispositions le gouvernement compte
prendre de lattes ce qui a déjà été
engagée pour premièrement réguler les
prix de l'immobilier à la baisse ils
sont trop élevés en france
deuxièmement faire que l'évolution des
loyers soient stoppés et par exemple on
pourrait imaginer que la pole hier elle
l'a dit si elle soit pendant trois ans
glace et si je n'ai pas d'augmentation
et enfin on sait que si on veut que
l'immobilier et notamment les coûts du
logement baissent il faut une production
massive de logements sociaux à un prix
abordable
or des engagements étaient pris par le
président de la république deux cent
cinquante mille logements
j'attire votre attention sur le fait que
tous les acteurs concernés considèrent
cet objectif ne pourra être atteint que
c'est la tva pour le logement social est
placée à 5 %
je plaide donc pour que pour la
compétitivité de la france ces mesures
soient prises
merci madame la ministre vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la sénatrice
vous avez raison de lier effectivement
la question de l'inflation immobilière
et celle de la compétitivité de
l'économie
que ce soit la compétitivité-prix
d'ailleurs où la compétitivité hors prix
sur la compétitivité prix la dégradation
s'est faite via deux canaux directement
via le prix des loyers et des
investissements immobiliers qui sont le
fait des entreprises indirectement aussi
vous l'avez dit du fed après la pression
sur les salaires nominaux puisque les
prix de l'immobilier pèsent sur le
pouvoir d'achat des ménages ce qui pèse
sur les salaires nominaux
par ailleurs les problèmes de logement
des salariés affecte aussi les
entreprises par d'autres biais en
affectant le recrutement en frais dans
la mobilité interne et salariés en
diminuant aussi leur productivité
autrement dit les tensions qui existent
aujourd'hui à la hausse sur le marché de
l'immobilier se répercute sur les
salariés et sur le marché du travail sur
la compétitivité hors prix également la
hausse des prix a pesé négativement par
deux biais en créant d'abord un effet
d'éviction puisque l'investissement et
bien immobilier se fait au détriment
d'autres investissements ou de dépenses
plus productives notamment en
machines-outils ou en recherche
développement
et puis deuxième billet en orientant
davantage d' épargne vers les crédits
immobiliers
plutôt que vers le financement des
entreprises auxquelles d'ailleurs il a
été fait allusion tout à l'heure alors à
l'occasion de ce débat et puisque vous
soulever la question de la tva
j'aimerais apporter une clarification
tout en précisant évidemment que la
question de la relance de la
construction de logements et notamment
de logements sociaux
elle vous le savez une préoccupation de
ce gouvernement est dans le cadre des
attributions de cécile duflot qui
travaille beaucoup sur ces chantiers
actuellement et est très mobilisé sur
ces chantiers actuellement sur la taux
de le taux de tva applicable au secteur
du logement social
je vous rappellerai juste que ce taux
est le fait du précédent gouvernement
c'est celui ci c'est le président
gouvernement qui avait choisi fin 2011
de faire passer la tva de 5,5 à 7 % et
donc en ce qui concerne les
augmentations des différents taux de tva
inscrite dans le troisième projet de loi
de finances rectificative pour 2012
je voudrais rappeler que ceux ci ne sont
applicables à compter du 1er janvier
2014 et que dans l'intervalle les taux
sont inchangés que le taux applicable au
logement social
tout comme pour les travaux de
rénovation thermique reste 7%
le premier ministre a eu vous l'avez vu
le sans doute l'occasion d'indiquer que
la question du relèvement des taux pour
certains secteurs comme le logement
social puisque c'est très une question
très critique fait l'objet d'un débat
dans un cadre budgétaire qui vous le
savez est extrêmement contraint ce débat
est actuellement en cours
le logement social et le logement
général est une des priorités du
gouvernement le droit tous nos
concitoyens à se loger dignement est
adroit absolument inaliénable
fondamentale et c'est pour cela qu'une
mobilisation très importante a été mise
en oeuvre pour le logement social
madame marie noëlle lienemann
oui madame la ministre merci de votre
réponse vous avez raison de dire que le
passage de 5,5 à 7 a été un handicap qui
est aujourd'hui constaté dans les chutes
des constructions de logements sociaux
néanmoins je me permets d'insister je l'
ai déjà fait dans ce avec certains de
vos collègues sur le fait que la thèse
selon laquelle la tva net applicable
qu'à actuellement de 7% oublie une
question majeure pour construire il faut
acheter des terrains quand un organisme
hlm veut acheter un terrain faut qu'ils
sachent comment il va boucler le
financement son opération
si aujourd'hui il boucle à cette toute
une série de terrain il peut pas les
acheter il frappe à l'opération si le
gouvernement annonce dès à présent que
le logement social qui est un bien de
première nécessité passe à 5
les organismes hlm pas faire la résa les
rf les réserves foncières nécessaires
qui si elles ne sont pas faites
aujourd'hui on n'aura pas les 150 mille
logements demain donc j'ai bien entendu
la volonté du gouvernement d'ouvrir le
débat je lui demande le conclure vite et
de le conclure avec une tva à 5 pour le
logement social
merci nous en avons fini avec des
questions cribles thématiques ou chers
collègues je le vois là pour la séance
de questions cribles thématiques
aujourd'hui consacré à la compétitivité
vous pourrez la revoir à tout instant
sur notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée à tous sur notre
chaîne